ええと。。俺の最初の誕生日
4月１日
これは俺の誕生日です。ｘ3
これは。。。はいどうぞ～
こんにちは
おおぉ～　トミー～
いやぁ～　はじめまして
おれもはじめまして
いやぁ～　はじめましてトミー～
僕もはじめまして
君は？
？？？？？？
おお～おｋ～　（えっと。。）
はじめまして。お久しぶりです
？？？？？？？？？？？？？？？？
こんにちは皆さん。僕の名前はHajimeです。
トミーです
お～イェイ～上手だ。
今日は、俺たちは英語のレッスンを始めます。
俺がすげぇ役に立つ英語話す。
おｋ？
ユスフルおｋ
君は「Useful」の意味は分かってる？
いいえ。
ああ。。。＊＊＊＊
おい。　PDRさん
これは、本当の英語レッスンです。
おｋ。レッスンを始めましょう。おｋ？
最初のレッスンは。。。
英語。新しい。単語。
「Word」の意味分かってる？
。
（これってたんごですか？）
俺はお前に新しい単語を教える。
新しい単語。おｋ
後に繰り返して言ってみて。おけ？
おけ
ええと。。最初の単語は。。「Onion」だお
後に繰り返して
「Onion」繰り返して。言って。
いえいえいえいえいえ。これを見て。おｋ？
おｋ
後に繰り返して
ありがとう。近い近い近いぞ～
もう一度、後に繰り返して
後に繰り返して
とても良いよ！ありがとう！　ｘ２
次の段階だ
次の段階？！
事務所じゃない方です
よし、俺の後に繰り返して
「Ice Cream]
言いえ
う～ん、あまりよくないな
後に繰り返して。見ろ
もう一回
「Ice Cream」
後に繰り返して
静かにして。ｘ４
Tシャツ貸します
後に繰り返して
「Tiger」
Tiger?
はい。俺の後に繰り返して
いえいえいえいえ。
後に繰り返して。おｋ？
「Tiger」
言いえ
今、俺たちは英語の単語（ひとつ）を学びました
でも、次は。。。俺たちは長い文を学びます
俺の。。。母は。。。ヘルメットです
大丈夫？意味が分かる？
じゃ、後に繰り返して
俺の母は。。。ヘルメットです
う～ん。まあまあかな？
もう一回
テンテンテンテンテーテテテテーテーテテテテー
つちゃつゃつゃつゃテテテテン！（やりきった）